foreign
that you're not a specialist
I'm using my joke
I'm also thinking do I have time to draw
another weapon can I kick can I close
and grapple
which means in the set I'm using the Joe
in a way
to stop him from being able to do those
things okay so as you're trying to study
both sides you reverse engineer the
forms so that
that's not possible okay if he's
stepping back for example in ishido 10
con
I reverse the form reverse engineer the
form to realize then then I must be
penetrating to the degree that brings
the logic to ushiro tenkon if I am not
penetrating to that degree he would be
able to draw another weapon maybe a
firearm or something like it's not
occupying him okay
so for example a real life uh training
we were working with simunitions in our
Law Enforcement Training
and we were practicing uh
combat
firearm combat around a vehicle it's a
specialized terrain it's not as easy as
someone might think and it doesn't mean
you can do it just because you can clear
a room or things like that
and one of the trainers who doesn't
really understand this concept said well
make sure you don't close so so much
that they'll come and they'll start
grappling you why would I bring a
firearm that close I'm going to uh to do
flanking Maneuvers and use the terrain
of the vehicle
but keep it in a firearm range do you
see I wouldn't close uh where this
person can start grappling over the
firearm so part of using a firearm
around a vehicle is making sure you
don't close so much that this person
feels there's more advantage to closing
and trying for a disarm than to stay in
the gut fight does that make sense okay
if I can't keep him in the gunfight then
I can't take advantage of the terrain
such as uh the pine the ABC pillars and
things like that very similar in here
okay so on the first
uh Joe's Key
he's going to do a Shiro tank on so
let's look at where his body is
okay and if my Joe ski only penetrates
the year he doesn't need to move at all
do you guys see that
so he could just pop me in the face
maybe just even this one
do you understand as I move into that
little range here
that's not going to cut it okay I have
to drive him back with the fear of I at
least
[Music]
so I can't go like this
do the technique nice
do the technique all the way
because the ma is wrong
okay so my my ski has to be able to
penetrate past that is where my ski is
you see that now depending on your range
of your leg length
you might have to
take a few steps
that's better than you coming out here
and doing this you're gonna
jack up the mind okay
so as he gives the opening that's where
I start to engage and I'm gonna come in
and skewer him forcing him to ishido
Tank on
comes around there's the month you guys
see that so even if you're going slow
which you guys are I want you to I still
have to penetrate pasta
you guys see that okay let's
so you're training embryonically
embryonically means that you're using
the Joe
your partners Joe
as kinesthetic vectors
the timing is not the same as in real
life if you were trying to use the Joe
in the technique okay so for example uh
slope he's gonna do the ski
I can use this line
as a kinesthetic Vector to tell me what
is the angle of my joke
so if I lift his weapon that this angle
here to the ground that's not the angle
of my Joe
that it should be or if I move his
weapon over
to my left
this is not the placement of my joke
so if I use his line as a kinesthetic
vector
I have to not move it not lift it and
that'll give me the angle of my kisser
so you can use it as a training device
don't move his weapon boom
if you do that
you should understand
how to because you can use it as a
training opportunity
it's a it's a martial strategy that you
hit whatever's nearest you especially in
weapons fighting so
don't be unconscious
with your hand placing it okay so as we
go for example he's going to do the
Kessa you're going to say and I'll
Shield my hand you're saying I don't
keep it here
as he's trying to do and use my show
embryonically I might get hit
but I want to take advantage and I have
to realize he's trying to defang the
snake so I'll Shield my hand you see
doesn't change anything
here like that
if you walk however
you need to know that's an embryonic
timing which means not the actual timing
I am not blocking this weapon I'm
deviating on that weapon
the actual uh movement means requires
that when he would have hit me I hit him
which means
I never touch his joke
I keep that same angle as before
but his Joe's not there
do you see
what I'm trying to do martially is take
some penetration off of his weapon take
some better look out because here comes
another ayuchi you see that so it's more
here boom
then the form continues okay so you do
even one is fine
but
when you do the kesa
you don't go here
there's no time
he goes there's no time for me do it for
really there's no time for me to hit
that you're doing two steps to his one
step
it's not required for the deviation
either I understand you're deviating
but it's not required
mushido tenkon has a rotation in there
it's usually done just out of habit
boom boom
or ignorance I either don't understand
what I'm actually trying to do
or I don't understand how to eat usido
tenkon get the angle deviation in it
okay so maybe you need to slow down more
maybe even let this go
and you'll rotate
into position
towards that end
your hands have to move already
so you can't go here
it's going to take too long
goes really slow okay my hands are
already moving towards it
hands are moving into the castle
from the very beginning wash my right
hand moves into the kissing
okay try it again
so
don't be in this
don't be at this speed outward stance
with your hands vertical
this is incorrect
is my hips not in the technique
my other hips not in the angle deviation
remember it had to pull back
and this is not where my power is
this is actually where my balance is so
gently push down on my hands
see where it's going there's no base
there
so as you rotate
don't move the foot
don't move it out
turn the foot
maybe you have to come around this side
turn the foot to pull the hip
foot turn is now on its angle that I
need
which is pointed at his spine
this is my sense
it's like Warrior books
my hands will be up and down
not this way
ain't nobody over here
with the hitting end
behind it
stick we go out
so I'm not hitting it
like tennis it's more like baseball
oh
my hands don't want to be parallel to
the part I'm hitting
I want some downwardness to it
over here
okay try it bring it in
stay there
the Joe is going around but your line of
attack is not circular
so well
yeah because in your body mind you
you're going around so I said it was
like Warrior one
no one does Warrior one like this
that your your instructor would come
over and go no no no no here do you see
so go back
just give me the line
okay there's this line
I'm going to be here
the weapon go back a point
doesn't want to lift it doesn't want to
go around but it also doesn't want that
weak angle
so I don't go weak here
and then around my head
I have that angle
it comes up just like Showman
and then my wrist will turn it's going
to come down my wrist turn boom is where
it is
so I don't go around my head
it just goes here
crap
so my angle
is going to go down if I didn't turn my
wrist show my new teeth if I turn my
wrist and bring my hip in it's gonna be
kissing okay pay attention go maybe over
this one
okay
so I was training embryonically and I
was using his weapon as the kinesthetic
vector
they teach me my because his weapons
representing the center line
so I'm going to Shield the center line
when I go to the actual timing I don't
I'm not going to give up the center line
see
I'm not sure you can see it from there
come back over here
say you go like this you're over here
you're not shielding the center line
you're going to Shield the center line
you see that
Shield boom
if you look at when you gave the opening
you're gonna give another opening over
here
so as you gave the opening that's where
it just goes around
you're moving around
your own Joe as much as you are his line
of attack you're going here you're
hiding behind your weapon
so don't move your weapon over here
you're not provide your weapon
Shield behind your weapon
it's just now not deflecting but you're
shielding behind your weapon
okay try it again
so you have the right timing right so if
I'm going in don't touch my door get it
beforehand here goes my attention whoa
I'm not going to be able to get back out
because his whole goal is to hit me as
I'm about there's no backing out of that
do you understand
so when I go skiing I go it's over
here
it's up the circle
do you understand it's not back out
there's no way you're going back out
it's impossible
so when you feel his weapon come around
you got to get over here
you got to move up the circle to the
zone to sanctuary
so uh
let's mark it so you can understand it
okay stay there
so there's my degree of penetration
okay and will Mark let us move a little
forward so that my back foot is on this
line
okay
go get your mind
cool just remember the timing you see
I'm not going to take this back but
and move
fewer of that and I'll never get there
the only way you can get there is you
didn't understand the initial
tiny so for example or the mine so
you're under penetrated
you get it okay then he was never going
to hit me anyways okay or
you waited
so you go here go ahead and hit my stick
and then I'm not waiting here why would
I wait there
why am I waiting here
it's just like Aikido that does uh ski
and it waits
punch combinations
so you have to follow a martial rule
that's Universal to all martial arts I
mean they're out of the way I'm either
out of range
or I'm hitting him before he hit me or
I'm hitting him as he hit me there's no
he strikes weights and then my turn
there's no martial art that does that
except Aikido just contemporary Ikea but
it's a deviation a degeneration
it's not how it's supposed to be okay so
as I ski I don't start understanding so
I can go backwards I have to penetrate
but I'm going to go forward
here to this circle here
got it
and it's just as smooth so as he's
moving smooth I'm moving smooth out to
here
cut it okay let's go
let me go back a little bit because it's
gonna come up as as I'm gonna change the
form from what Sensei did and I'll
explain why okay
so when I first learned the form from
Sensei it had a front crossover
step out
into Kessa
and I always up here
and then later can't you say he started
changing it because you had to start
doing this for the person that actually
penetrated
marshley like since they wanted you to
so you started to see this
and it's like ah you're just you're
making a fetish out of the footwork you
see okay but
secondarily in all of my application of
the art whether it be in our giwasa or
live environments or out in the field I
have never
done the front crossover
okay
um and when you look at the whole of the
form
the whole of the form is really about
ushito tenkon
which comes up a lot in those other
environments you do oh shoot a tank on a
lot so if you look at uh Gateway
Aikido video number 15 where we're
looking at giwasa more live environments
it's constantly ushito tenkan constantly
okay because that's how you deal with
aggression with Shield tank on okay so
as I'm doing as I'm doing this form
that's why I go to this technique okay
so if you look at it
in terms of angle deviation okay he has
uh just Soldier Joe out of the way
this is representing the thrust of my
ski that Force okay so it don't move
your body it's pushing straight from my
12 to his six Okay so
he's going to go around that Force
and that's what makes it the deviation
you see
put that in your other hand
his chest size here
you see okay and its energy is going
that way so make a Fists
and that force is here
so you're going to see what I'm going to
do is not try to come back out
I'm going to blend in with that Force
and eventually just because the way a
circle inside of the square works I'm
going to be out of range of that Force
you see that
so that's what I'm trying to do
as we go we go a little slower
I'm going to do the same over
penetration so Mark where his spine is
in space I'm going to do the same spinal
displacement of an actual assaultive
attack you're going to see that it goes
way past that
and then
I am going to now take what I learned in
those Force factors and see where they
apply when his hips change directions
okay so in other words you're going to
look for a spinal displacement but
you're going to watch his hips change
the vector you're going to see that my
hips stay connected to his hips that way
I'll neutralize those Force vectors okay
so you're going to watch all that boom
I'm going this way
if we take away the joke
you'll watch his hips boom
boom
so if you watch my back foot now
it's not going there that's too late he
already changed the vector I'm too late
that would be
like in any fight I'm staying still and
he already moved I'm not moving at his
intention so watch my back foot now it's
not doing what you thought it was doing
as I come in
I relate my back foot and my hips to his
hips
if he didn't move
it still would work but if he didn't
move his hands there'd be no point for
me to have to move when he moved you see
that so I keep that back foot there it's
no different
if we're here and I'm going to throw my
punch and I see his deviation deviating
some way you see
I'm not gonna throw that punch over here
because now I'm looking the wrong way so
once I see his hips move I have to move
my hips with his hips so I'm not looking
the wrong way okay
going back to video 15 I have to move at
the level of intention I can't wait for
these things to Over Manifest okay so
let's try it again
says this this is something when I train
with uh under Mr Parker
so the founder of the American tempo
so
he's looking at historical
uh Chinese forms and he's trying to give
it some sort of scientific
um conceptual breakdown okay so he came
with up with this concept called zones
of sanctuary
and to help people understand it
he said
if you take a circle
and you draw a square around that Circle
and you shade in the circle
there's going to be areas of the square
that are not shaded in
okay so if you take your clock principle
they're at the angles do you see
so to speak
okay if you look at your Aikido uh
spiraling footwork that we've been going
over
you move into those corners
don't go on the 12 to 6 or the nine to
six line or you are in a shaded part of
the circle
the Shaded part of the circle represents
in the middle is the person's spine
and these are their limbs
all the angles that their limbs can hit
got it
okay
so for example if you throw a strike to
my face boom
here I am at six o'clock I am in the
Shaded part of the circle
and if I start moving
uh up the circle and in he will stay
you see how I'm pushing into it you see
he's gonna hit me but if I stay on the
circumference of the circle and I move
to that unshaded part of the square
you'll see that I come off of it
you see okay
so that it doesn't change if he has is
Joe
there it is
I'm going to move off of it
and you'll be out of it okay
I don't need the extra range of having
to come back out
that's going to take time and require
space and in this case I don't have
either one I don't have time okay so
what I do instead is I'm going to uh
move up the circle
so I hit that zone of sanctuary
then I'm where I want to be
okay I don't want to be way out of it
because you're not going to be able to
do Mafia tush
you're gonna you'll do some Joe weird
Joe fake stuff that you won't be Mafia
toast for the attacks and sounds okay so
make sure that that's your concept here
I'll see okay I see and I go here
this is where I go again if you're just
tracking the hits that's where you go if
you ski and you come back here our hips
are not looking at each other you see
that
they're not matching rotation I scan my
hips rotate with his hips you're going
to be in that zone sanctuary okay try it
again
okay so now we're in machia touch and
you can train Market plus embryonically
again that is what I'm going to use his
Joe is a kinesthetic Vector to learn the
angles I need on my weapon okay and I
always don't move his Joe his Joe is
what I go around okay it's representing
young energy it's representing my angles
of deviation and my angles of deflection
as a as a orientation okay so I'll ski
you'll see I'm moving up here all right
he's now going to make it uh that Vector
he's not it's not kesaruchi anymore
I come up I don't move I don't lift it I
don't move it
it's just a training vector
so from here I'm gonna go around it
without moving it and without separating
I go around it and down it
then I gotta make sure that I bathe the
my again because his next move is harai
he's gonna do a Shiro ten Twan so I
reverse engineered the my and you'll see
stay there you'll see that I have the
same degree of penetration so he does
and you'll see I'll use that same shield
in my hand which is his attack in this
case okay it's not up to him to miss my
hand because that'll jack up his
orientation you see how open he is on
this side you know he hits my hand okay
so if I want to do machiotosh
embryonically you'll see the form kind
of stops
and I go around
and we'll end it here with that degree
of penetration
what you want to understand again when
you train embryonically
that's not the application the timing is
off the my is off okay it's a training
tool
if you want you can do the right timing
but let me show you why the embryonic is
not an accurate application of Mafia
tush okay which a lot of people think it
is so I know this is a block
that's not ipeto and it won't work
Mafia Tosh is a stop hit on his hands
so it hits his joke way before that
Kessa comes around so my mindset is
assaulted so as I do my first ski we'll
go slow so I can talk about my mindset
I'm going to do violence of action crap
keep moving forward
the guy moved his hips so I followed
accordingly and I keep on attacking
forward
you add this key to it
and you'll see that I'm really just
doing violence of action
slow and smooth
I keep moving forward
okay
you can train either one but make sure
it's one or the other and not a
combination of both okay let's go